America how are you doing or should we
say should we say Astrid Astrid yeah I
am channeling some master tonight for
sure how is it easier the second time
around the second time around with the
baby baby wise it's different it's
different
I mean easier in that you kind of know
what to expect but different cause every
pregnancy is different
you're not as nervous though are you
you're kind of like I got this how
pregnant you are you're ready all right
how do you get ready to do the Oscars
red carpet but also still you want to do
the maternity thing how did you do how
do you mix those two together well you
know I I happen to love my pregnant body
I mean the first time I was pregnant it
was you know being in my body in a
totally different way and it feels
wonderful to celebrate that I for
tonight I wanted to say farewell to my
character Astrid so definitely wanted a
sort of warrior queen vibe but the
headband i'm wearing is actually
inspired by the warriors of my my own
indigenous tribe in honduras the lincoln
people love that magnificent it's
beautiful
[Music]